When Paul says, "The Lord Jesus Christ
created all things in heaven and on
earth, visible things, invisible things,
whether thrones, dominions,
principalities, or powers." Isn't
that an explicit and ambiguous
affirmation that Jesus created the whole
creation, the entire
creation, all the heavens and everything
in them, the entire earth and everything
on it, every created thing that
exists? Okay, so let me ask a follow-up
question. Does that include Satan and
evil
spirits? Were they part of the all
things in heaven that are invisible to
us that Jesus Christ, our Lord,
created? Okay, here's where Matt saw
where I was going with this, but didn't
want to address it. I'm not putting
down. I'm just saying. Now, let's look
at Colossians 1:20. and having made
peace through the blood of his cross. By
him, now notice the language, to
reconcile all things unto himself, by
him I see it, we say, whether they be
things in earth or things in heaven. Oh
boy. And having made peace through the
blood of his cross, by him to reconcile
all things unto himself, by him I say,
whether they be things in earth or
things in heaven. Oh boy.
Oh boy. What Paul is doing by
inspiration of the Holy Spirit, let me
explain to you what Paul is doing by
inspiration of the Holy Spirit. By
inspiration of the Holy Spirit, Paul is
saying the one who created everything in
the entire creation is the same one who
came to save everything in the entire
creation. So if you admit to me that in
1617 all things in heaven and earth
means every creature in existence then
in verse 20 when it says he reconciled
all things whether in earth or in heaven
making peace by the blood of his Christ
then all things there must also mean
every
creature. If Satan is part of the all
things that Jesus Christ our Lord
created in heaven, then he's also part
of the all things that Jesus Christ our
Lord made reconciliation for making
peace by the blood of his cross. So then
does that mean Satan's redeemed? No.
That's my point. No. Let me explain.
Now, what I was trying to get at is if
Matt is consistent with the way he
interprets Colossians 2:14, then he has
no choice to say that since Jesus
actually made peace by the blood of his
cross and actually reconciled all things
in earth and in the heavens, then Matt
has to now admit everything is savable
and will be saved, including
Satan, according to the way the Matt
interpreted Colossians 2:14. So, let me
explain. If Matt is right that when
Colossians 2:14 says, "Jesus nailed the
written
charges against
us to the cross and took it away." And
that
means that only the elect can be saved.
Because if Jesus nailed the written
charges to the cross and removing it
completely from everyone, then everyone
has to be saved. You see the
point? So therefore, Matt has to now
argue the same way with Colossians 1.
Man has to now say, "All
right, since Jesus is the one who made
peace by the blood of his cross to
reconcile all things on earth and in
heaven, then that means everything on
earth and heaven will be saved because
Jesus made peace by his blood for
everything on earth and heaven and
reconciled everything on earth and
heaven."
I was showing the problem with Matt's
interpretation of Colossians 2:14 that
if he's going to be consistent, he has
to apply the way he's interpreting
Colossians 2:14 to Colossians
1, which he did not
do. You get the
point? He did not do. And he kept
saying, "Well, Satan won't be saved."
Exactly, Matt. Why won't he be saved? He
kept saying because Jesus didn't redeem
or accomplish redemption for him. No,
that's not the reason. Let me explain
it. Satan won't be saved not because
Jesus didn't accomplish redemption for
even Satan. Colossians 1 says Jesus
perfectly accomplished redemption for
the entire creation that he created.
So that's not the reason why Satan won't
be saved. The reason why he won't be
saved is because what Jesus
accomplished must be received by
faith. Accomplishing salvation,
redemption is not the same thing as
applying
it. This is what he did not want to
accept because then that means his view
of limit atonement is not
true. You understand now? Is it clear
now? So, why isn't Satan saved? The
answer isn't because Jesus didn't offer
or accomplish redemption,
reconciliation, salvation for Satan.
Because Colossians 1 says what it says,
guys. You can't get around it.
Colossians 1 says what it says. I didn't
write Colossians 1. Paul did by
inspiration Holy Spirit. And Paul
clearly says in verse 20 of Colossians
1, he made peace by the blood of his c
cross to reconcile all things to himself
whether on earth or in heaven. Live with
it. That's Paul's language by
inspiration of Holy Spirit. I didn't
write it. Paul
did. So it's not that
Satan isn't saved because Jesus didn't
accomplish redemption even for Satan. He
most certainly did. The reason why Satan
isn't saved is
because Satan will not believe in Jesus
Christ and repent toward Jesus Christ
and live for Jesus Christ and obey Jesus
Christ in order to appropriate what
Jesus has
accomplished. You see my point?
That's the problem. We have no
indication that Satan or demons can
repent. Why do I say that? Because Satan
and demons have become so encrusted in
evil that now evil has become second
nature to them, instinctive to them.
It's now their DNA. It defines them. And
this is what the Bible warns if the
Bible warns us that if you make sin
habitual sin becomes something you
habitually do in time. It's not
something you do. It's now something
that is instinctive to you. You cannot
help but do that sin because you've
engaged in it so much. You've done that
sin so much. It now becomes second
nature to you. It's now part of your
DNA. It defines you because it starts
out by a choice. But because you
habitually engage in that thing, it goes
from being a choice to something
inescapable that you
cannot escape from and you have no
choice but to do because it now defines
you. It's part of your makeup, your DNA.
It becomes second
nature. And that's by the way true of
everything. I'll give you example.
Boxing. Let's take
boxing. What happens to a person who
who's who in practices boxing for 30 40
years? His
neurons, his
muscles have been trained to such a
level that now it's instinctive. It's
reflexive. He doesn't have to think. He
just does.
Right? Why do you think I keep telling
you guys we are creatures of repetition?
We must hear something repetitively
until it becomes second nature by the
grace of God. Why do you think I keep
saying
that?
Right? Why do you think I keep saying
that? And this is true of lifestyle
choices. When you choose to engage in a
sin over a period of time, that sin
defines you. You're so encrusted in that
sin, that sin is so engraved into you,
you can't choose not
to act on that sin and carry out that
sin. So, how does it tie in with Satan
and demons? Satan and demons are so
encrusted in their sin. The sin is so
engraved in them that they're now
defined by that sin, evil, and evil
defines them. They cannot help but do
evil because it's their
DNA.
Right? Is everything making
sense? Right. So, let me show you where
Jesus says. John 8:44. John 8:44. Now
notice what our Lord says about Satan's
makeup, his DNA. Look what our Lord
says. John
8:44. Ye are of your father the devil.
Ye are of your father the devil. And the
lust of your father ye will do. He was a
murderer from the beginning and abode
not in the truth. He refused to abide in
the truth. Because there is no truth in
him. When he speaketh a lie, he speaketh
of his own. For he is a liar and the
father of it. See, when he lies, it's
second nature. He can't help but lying.
He can't choose not to lie because
that's his
nature. So is it possible for Satan and
demons to repent? Not anymore. They've
re reached a level of reprobation and
evil. They can't choose
contrarily. Can't do it
anymore. And you know that's also true
of certain human beings. Let me give you
the verses. We're not going to read
them, but I want you to write these
down. Write down Romans 1
24-32. Romans 1 24- 24-32. Romans 1:es
24-32. Yes, Hannah. Romans 1 24-32. I'm
giving you the verses specifically
Romans 1:24 26 and 28. And then also
write down 2 Thessalonians
2:es 9-12. Write down guys 2
Thessalonians 2:es 9 and 12. Write it
down.
And now let me show you Jeremiah
13:23. This is also true with spiritual
habits, whether good or bad. People who
fast and pray for hours and days on end,
reach a level where fasting and prayer
become second
nature. And they can't help but fast and
pray. And if they don't fast and
pray, they
feel at a loss and it affects them
psychologically.
So you can become addicted to good
spiritual habits where it becomes second
nature and you can't choose
contrarily or you can choose to indulge
in evil spiritual habits where then you
reach a level where those evil choices
now define
you. Right? Only God can miraculously
then change you at that